we are now joined by the winner of
magnus carlson huge congratulations
thank you so magnus we saw that
celebration what words
describe your feelings right now um i'm
really really
relieved um
i mean i i sort of sort of felt
after yesterday that i sort of gotten
away with one but i knew it would still
be difficult today
uh and
um
no i i i don't think
any of us played a particularly
good match but yeah i don't i don't care
about that right now
i'm just so happy to have to have one
one of these uh tournaments and it feels
really really good
yeah and why now uh what went right this
time that hasn't
gone your way the four previous
tournaments i think to be honest i was a
little luckier this time
ah i think that's that's it uh
i feel like my play was probably a
little bit better last time out
uh but i had the necessary luck
this this time and i think overall
in in the tour uh
it's not unfair that i finally
finally win one but that it turned out
to be this one was yeah a little bit
lucky
and is it also a little bit about timing
we know the candidates finish
sort of initiating the world chess
championship year
sort of motivation maybe just the rising
to the top
no i don't i i mean i i would give you
some very advanced um explanations if
there were any i just
really really think that uh
um i my level wasn't that different from
from other tournaments maybe like
considering uh considering the last one
maybe a little bit
worse uh even but it just fell fell for
me this time but
yeah i don't care about that right now
magnus you mentioned a bit of luck and
today didn't start off in the perfect
fashion
what do you think what the turning point
was
um no so i
i uh um
i i made a a few poor decisions in the
opening he was clearly
well uh well prepared and i just
chose uh a poor continuation
at some point uh then yeah i actually
got some
some chances i could even have one at
some point
and i saw that a couple of moves later
that's why i was really really
upset there um
[Music]
i think for me one turning point was
the second game
[Music]
since after he took on c3 and
then on f3 i saw that gf was was a draw
by force
and then sort of out of inertia i made i
played queen
d2 uh and after i made the merquen d2 i
realized that
um you could just go b6 retreat as
bishop
and my position is is awful especially
considering
that's another thing that i've missed if
i if i try and develop
the to b2 um he has
this trick with knight c4 and
yeah my position is just it's just awful
um so i mean
so i after after i'd realized
that he was he was much better there uh
i even like briefly uh considered going
94
after we repeated once but then yeah i
finally i hope that he would repeat
again and uh
um i sort of felt like i i'd gotten away
with
with one there um
because after that obviously it's not a
great situation but
it's still two games and i have to win
one of them so
that's it could be could be a lot worse
so yeah if you want to look for turning
points today this was certainly it so
you were surprised by his decision to
take the draw there
not shocked i think he probably was just
in the mindset that the draw was
was good and even if he felt that he was
somewhat better
um he would take a draw if he felt that
he was much better
uh he might have played on but i think
uh
i didn't get the impression that he was
very very confident
throughout the match in general
and this was probably a um prime example
of that
all right well magnus since you have one
today we uh always
interact with our viewers on twitter
with a quiz of today and i really want
to ask you
the quiz of today and i hope you want to
answer so the question is
uh if you go where'd you go to a karaoke
bar what would be sort of your go-to
[Laughter]
song
another time okay so you're not going to
celebrate with karaoke today then
or can i ask you one question
so we've been setting a challenges for
poor david howell
and uh we saw you successfully wipe the
floor in the chili chest challenge but
what kind of challenge would you like to
see david do next
or vancouver
uh i'll i'll have to i'll have to get
back to you
uh i think your minds are anyway
a lot more devious than
well magnus we did see you in that chili
challenge was it really
that easy for you or did you think it
was spicy as well
no it wasn't spicy at all it was fun
you should have uh level and do it
another time
okay he eats chili like they're like
their chips
or candy all right i think we have to do
that
he'd be a worthy more than worthy
opponent all right well we should have
you against levon in the chili challenge
then
i guess maybe maybe all right magnus
uh we're so happy for you huge
congratulations on the win and the new
inches classic
thank you so much thanks for joining us